Eric Foster here with another new rock  stars hot take never before seen set  video reveals that the Scarlet Witch was  originally also going to kill Bolton the  brave Thor's half-brother played by  Daniel Craig in Doctor Strange in the  Multiverse of Madness in the earliest  balder rumors also reported that a  standard for Michael Fassbender Magneto  was also going to be part of the shoot  if so that would make the a38 Wanda  maximoff Magneto's daughter and Evan  Peters Pietro her brother and the full  a3a Universe the same universe as the  fox X-Men universe that's probably why  Charles Xavier quoted his exact line  from X-Men Days to Future Past and now  838 Wanda is left in that Universe to  take the blame for killing Charles and  all the Illuminati leaders wow